مرحبا انا ليلى الشخلي لنتابع معا ابرز
اخبار الاسبوع الماضي بايجاز وضمن ابرز
الاحداث بغداد تطرد سفيره السويد جنود
الاحتياط في تل ابيب يهددون بسبب
التعديلات القضائيه موجه حر غير مسبوقه
تجتاح العالم واخبار اخرى لنتابعها معا
نبدا نشرتنا من المظاهرات التي خرجت في
العراق بسبب سماح السلطات السويديه
والدنماركيه بحرق نسخ من المصحف الشريف
والعلم العراقي امام سفاره العراق في
ستوكهولم وكوبنهاجن وقد اقتحم متظاهرون
سفاره السويد وابرموا النار فيها الحكومه
العراقيه قررت طرد سفيره السويد وسحبت
القائمه بالاعمال في ستوكهولم مستنكره ما
وصفتها بالمواقف السويديه المستفزه لعقائد
الاخرين في المقابل وصفت الخارجيه
السويديه لاقتحام بغير المقبول واستدعت
السفيره العراقيه بدورها استدعت السعوديه
وقطر وايران سفراء السويد وسلمتهم مذكرات
احتجاج تندد وتطالب بوقف الاعتداء على
مقدسات المسلمين رواد منصات التواصل
تفاعلوا بشده مع هذه التطورات لنقرا بعض
التغريدات
ديني نسيمه تقول ليت كل الدول العربيه
والاسلاميه تحدث حذو العراق وتطرد سفيره
السويد شر طرطه اما صاحبه حساب فتقول
الغرب بفهمش الا لغه القوه والمال مقاطعه
اقتصاديه فقط اللي بتادبهم ولا التنديدات
والشجب لا بيقدم ولا باخر اعذارهم جاهزه
حريه التعبير
اذا كانت هذه ابرز التغريدات من بغداد الى
تل ابيب حيث اغلق الاف المتظاهرين الشوارع
واقتحموا مبنى البورصه رفضا لما وصفوه
بانقلاب حكومه نتنياهو وذلك في ظل سعي
تحالف اليمين المتطرف لتمرير تغييرات في
النظام القضائي في الكنيست الاسرائيلي
وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه تقول ان اكثر من
الف من وحدات سلاح الجو يعلنون وقف
خدماتهم بالاحتياط رفضا لخطط اضعاف القضاء
ومئات من جنود الاحتياط يخرجون في مسيره
مهددين برفض الخدمه التطوعيه اذا مضت
الحكومه قدما في خطتها بدوره قال رئيس
اركان الجيش ان الدعوات للامتناع عن
الخدمه العسكريه تمس بالجيش وبامن اسرائيل
شاركونا اراءكم في التعليقات ما
السيناريوهات المتوقعه للازمه في تل ابيب
مع رفض جنود الاحتياط للخدمه العسكريه
الان الى موجه الحر غير المسبوقه التي
تضرب شمال الكره الارضيه في امريكا
واوروبا وافريقيا واسيا قالت المنظمه
العالميه للارصاد الجويه ان مطلع الشهر
الجاري كان الاسبوع الاشد حراره على
الاطلاق في كوكب الارض ما اجمل السلطات في
عدد من الدول لاتخاذ تدابير صارمه للتعامل
مع تداعياتها في اليونان مثلا تواصل فرق
الاطفاء مكافحه حرائق اندلعت في الغابات
ومناطق اخرى شرق العاصمه اليونانيه اثينا
بسبب الموجه كما اصدرت السلطات هناك اوامر
باجلاء منتجعات سياحيه واجلاء مئات السكان
في بلدات محيطه بالعاصمه وفي تونس تواصل
وحدات من الحمايه المدنيه والجيش التونسي
جهود السيطره على حرائق اندلعت في غابات
بمنطقه ملوله في مدينه طبرقه شمال غربي
البلاد وينضم الان الينا من عمان محمد
الشاكر مدير موقع طقس العرب
مرحبا محمد ما السبب موجه الحر غير
المسبوقه هذه وما علاقه حرائق الغابات بها
تزامن القبب الحراريه في نصف الكره
الشمالي ادى الى هذا النوع من الموجات
الحاره التي اتسمى بانه واسع النطاق في
مناطق مختلفه بعض من هذه الموجات الحاره
كانت مميزه بانها كسرت ارقاما قياسيه
سابقه لدرجات الحراره من حيث الارتفاع
وبعض الموجات الاخرى كانت مميزه بينها
طويله زمنيه فكره الحالتين دائما ما ترتبط
درجات الحراره المرتفعه بموجات الحر
بحرائق الغابات فبالرغم من ان حرائق
الغابات دائما قد تبدا من انشطه بشريه الا
ان ازديادها وانتشارها تكون بسبب الحر
الكبير الذي يؤثر على المناطق الحرجيه
والذي يؤدي الى جفاف الاغصان وانتشار
الحرائق شكرا محمد بحزمه صفقات اقتصاديه
واستثماريه وتجاريه اختتم الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان في الامارات جوله خليجيه
بداها زياره المملكه العربيه السعوديه
التي انتقل منها الى قطر قبل قدومه الى
ابوظبي وقع الجانبان التركي والسعودي
مذكره تفاهم في مجال الدفاع تشمل شراء
المسيرات التركيه بهدف رفع جاهزيه القوات
المسلحه السعوديه وفي قطر عقد الجانبان
قمه ثنائيه تناولت عددا من الملفات المهمه
تصدرتها العلاقات الثنائيه والشراكه
الاستراتيجيه بين البلدين كما وقعت تركيا
مع الامارات اتفاقيات ومذكرات تفاهم تبلغ
قيمتها نحو 50 مليار دولار ويمكنكم متابعه
المزيد عن مجريات زياره في التقرير اسفل
التعليقات والان الى اخبارنا الرياضيه هذا
الاسبوع اذ قال كريستيانو رونالدو انه لن
يعود للعب في اوروبا ويؤكد انه يرى ان
الدوري السعودي للمحترفين افضل من دوري
المحترفين الامريكي الذي اختاره غريمه
لينا المس كما اعتبر انه مهد الطريق امام
لاعبين كبار اخرين للانتقال الى فرق
السعوديه
وينضم الان الينا عمار نامق عمار قبل ان
تذهب الى النشره اعرف ان لديك اخبار جديده
عن سوق الانتقالات الصيفيه وخصوصا اخبار
عن مبابي على ما يبدو
هذا اللاعب قبل قليل اعلن باريس سان
جيرمان انه لن يكون ضمن الجوله
الاستعداديه في اليابان لاعب بهذا الحجم
باريس سان جيرمان يعلن انه هذا اللاعب لن
يكون ضمن هذه الجوله ومثل ما نعرف ليلى
هذه جولات جدا مهمه بدنيا
ذهنيا تحضير وترويج ايضا للنادي لعب بهذه
القيمه لن يكون هناك ما يدل بين السطور
على انه هناك مرحله جديده وعاهد جديد بين
باريس سان جيرمان بقيمه مدرب جديد
في هذه الفتره انتقالات ايضا الانتقالات
الصيفيه هذه سوق محموم يبدو من من الامور
المثيره والمفرحه ان الثلاثي برشلونه اصبح
الان وين في امريكا في انتر ميامي ميسي
بوسكيس وتوجه لهم الابا مع
المدرب الذي كان ايضا في برشلونه اذا عهد
جديد لهذا النادي بحله وبنكهه كتلونيه
ومرحله جديده طبعا شكرا جزيلا
[ضحك]
على المتابعه
[موسيقى]